this is Startalk Mike Johnson from
Barstow California asks how close would
an alien civilization have to be to
discover earth using the same technology
we have here oh that is a fabulous
question now just to talk more about me
when I took astronomy from Carl Sagan
this is yeah did you put it back now I
was just in the room I was just one guy
so we had must have been a fun class it
was cool so we had this image of this
organism eating little organisms
ingesting them and spitting him as
astronomy yeah and it turned out to be
an image of a swimming pool taken from a
satellite so you have to get
extraordinarily close to really a
determine whether or not something's
alive or or you'll get fooled right but
I think they need to be pretty close to
us like couple meters yeah we have we
just left the solar system now right
with voyagers yeah they couldn't be much
further than that so I guess so
hopefully they're just on the other end
but
[Music]